(bass music)
(techno music)
(kissing noises)
- Yo, dude!
- Hey, what's up, Squat Sauce?
- Hey, why don't you tell
me what's up, Street Meat?
- Oh, you know I'm just
sizzling on the street, dog.
- Gotta do it, gotta do it.
- [Video Game] Divekick!
- Dude.
- What?
- This was just what I...
I like this game because it
settles my brain down after
a long day of getting
scalded by, fucking carnitas.
- You got hot carnitas where you're at?
- Yeah, dog.
Yeah, I'm working at the Taco Bin.
- Do you get any discount on your tacos?
- Yeah, I get diarrhea for free, man.
- [Video Game] Select your character.
- I can't decide which
one of these players
I want to play.
- I'm going to do this lady, Kung Pao,
with sensitive skin.
- Great.
- I like to wear my hat
when I go in the garden,
otherwise, my Melanoma
will really flare up.
- [Video Game] Death from above!
- Oh he's...ahhhhh.
- I caused an earthquake
by kicking your head.
- [Video Game] Round two.
- You just shot me with your fire-butt!
- That is some lightning kick, dude.
Lightning's got some kick!
- What is his diet that
fire comes out of his ass?
- [Video Game] Round four.
- I feel his kick would be much better at
this if he took his hands
out of his fucking pockets.
- Well, what's he going to do
with his hands in Divekick?
- I don't know.
- He's being responsible,
he don't wanna use it.
- Maybe counter-balance, man.
- [Video Game] Round two.
Divekick.
- Why is my head getting so big?
- I hope your head explodes.
- Your head is big but not as big as mine.
- [Video Game] Jefailey, wins!
(sniffing sounds)
- Dude, Santa Monica
City College is kicking
my dick in right now.
- Really?
- Taking this Theater of
the West Indies Class--
- So you're upset about
the class you're taking?
- There's this girl.
- Talk it out, talk it out,
talk it out, what's her name?
- Teacher just calls her Miss Rodriguez.
She's, like, Puerto Rican or...
- Miss Rodriguez?
Is she older?
- The teacher is this old, fucking dude
with a goatee.
And he, like, refers to all of
us as Mr. and Mrs. Something,
you know, like, I think I love her dude.
- Whoa!
- She's one of those, like,
some sort of ethnic girl
with really bright blue eyes.
She's either Indian, or
Black, or Cuban, or--
- Either way, win-win.
- Whatever it is, it's
my favorite country,
because fuck dude, she's
just electric, you know.
- Call her, ask her out.
- Can't ask her out, dude.
- What do you want?
You're an adult?
- I gotta ease into it, dude.
I think I'm gonna roll
a pencil down the stairs
in the class, and then have to go--
- Hi, is this Miss Rodriguez?
- Ha, ha, you're fucking hilarious.
- Hello?
I'm in your, um--
- Are you serious?
- Theater of the West Indies Class.
You're not?
Fuck you, I don't believe
you, dude, you're not...
- Yeah, at SMCC--
- You're not fucking talking to her.
- Yeah.
- Are you talking to her?
- I think you're great.
- Fucking hang up.
- And I would love to
take you out to dinner.
- Please stop.
- My name is Squat Sauce.
Herman Squat Sauce.
- Fuck you, dude.
- Yeah.
- All right, well I'll
see you Friday at eight.
- No, fuck you dude.
- All right.
- Miss Rodriguez!
- Well, I miss you already too.
- Hang up!
- Okay, bye.
- Miss Rodriguez, hang up.
It's not me.
- You hang up.
This is nuts.
You...I'm gonna hang up
'cause my battery's low.
All right, I'll see you Friday.
(reveal music)
- Oh, why the fuck would you do that?
- I know we're supposed to game on Friday
night but I kinda had these plans come up
out of nowhere.
- Oh, fuck, my chest hurts.
- That voice came through that phone and I
was, like, Whooop!
You're from someplace I don't know.
- What the fuck is wrong with you, dude?
- Nothing, I'm going on a
date with a beautiful woman.
- [Video Game] Stuck in controller line.
Mister N wins!
No, you do not.
- [Video Game] Divekick.
(walking sounds)
- Miss Rodriguez?
(foghorn sound)
Hi, I'm sorry, I was looking
for a Miss Rodriguez, you're?
(tinkling music)
Eh, I've done worse.
(upbeat music)